[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Now that Nougat has
begun to roll out,
it's a good time to review
the many security enhancements
included.
Check out the post for info on
direct boot encryption, media
stack and platform hardening,
apps security improvements,
and more.
We're now taking applications
for the third class
at the Launchpad Accelerator.
If you're a late stage
apps startup from Brazil,
India, Indonesia, or
Mexico, check out this post.
Applications are
open until October 24
for the equity-free program
that begins in January
and includes two
weeks of all expense
paid training at the new Google
Developers Launchpad space
in San Francisco.
If you're about to launch
a new holiday campaign,
you could, for example,
use TrueView ads
on YouTube along with banner ads
on the Google Display Network
to drive brand awareness
and more holiday sales.
To make it easier for
you to track and forecast
the performance
of these campaigns
against your
advertising goals, we're
introducing campaign groups
and performance targets.
More info and screenshots
are on the post.
Beginning with Chrome
56 in January of 2017,
we'll mark HTTP sites that
transmit password or credit
cards as nonsecure as
part of a long-term plan
to mark all HTTP
sites as nonsecure.
HTTPS is easier and
cheaper than ever before.
Check out the post for
details on our upcoming change
as well as a setup
guides to help
you get started with HTTPS.
Cloud Tools for
PowerShell is a collection
of commandlets for accessing
and manipulating GCP resources.
It's currently in beta
and already allows access
to Google Compute Engine, Google
Cloud Storage, Google Cloud
SQL, and Google Cloud
DNS with more to come.
For more info on how to get
started, check out the post.
If you've been considering
moving your web surfing
infrastructure to the cloud,
our recently published Serving
Websites Guide is for you.
It covers static websites,
virtual machines, containers,
and manage platforms.
For each, the guide
provides information
about scalability, load
balancing, DevOps, logging
and monitoring, and more.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]